[Musik]
wenn eine krankheit
unser leben bestimmt
wenn wir ihr ausgeliefert sind
welche risiken wären wir bereit
einzugehen wenn uns eine operation ein
normales leben schenken könnte würden
wir akzeptieren mit unserer krankheit zu
leben oder alles aufs spiel setzen wenn
wir ein ziel so klar vor augen haben und
für die hoffnung nicht aufgeben können
welche entscheidung würden wir treffen
morgen ist ein vorzeige die wichtigsten
dem platz
nun ist es amtlich die bedingung die
definitiven operation kommt eigentlich
die wahl entscheidend ist abgesprochen
mit texten beweissicher fest dass ich
nicht alles gemacht ist die sache wird
hat das schicksal sie aber fachlich sind
es bruder und schwester und ich vertraue
und hoffe dass ich jetzt genau mehr dazu
erfahren dass bures letzte runde
möglich wird die post hofft man sich
jetzt das kurz zeigen
[Musik]
dies ist die geschichte von nicola eine
geschichte geprägt von zermürben dem
kontrollverlust und von dem unbändigen
wunsch nach einem selbstbestimmten leben
[Musik]
wirklich gemacht hat er hat ganze
gesellschaft am sonntagabend unterhalb
der und allen gelagerten ich wirklich so
der klonkrieger mit der gestik und
einfach es um fröhlich und aktiv sind
die namen als agenda benützt das
unglaublich kurz gedächtnis kann
und irgendwo zwischen bis können auf
straßen mit glock sei und er hat das
nach einem neuen blog
[Musik]
die vierköpfige familie mit vater chili
und bruder sven ahnte damals noch nicht
was auf sie zukommen wird
schon recht früh der unterstufen heute
sport im alltag ich lege zu so gut sie
konnten das so beschrieben wie blöd ich
plötzlich hatte er nämlich in erlassen
das ist ganz wichtig sie wollen das hat
funktioniert und vor allem darauf trifft
das nicht gegangen
ich mag mich an erster vfb haben
erinnere beständigkeit von acht schulen
und ich und ich gefastet hat wählen
das glas wasser nehmen die jury der
bewegung verhalten und dass ich ein paar
sekunden gegangen hat einfach geht
wieder weiter knochen und körperteilen
equipment mit dem kopf oder
nach weiteren sichtbaren
bewusstseinsstörungen sogenannten
absenzen wird nicola im alter von zehn
jahren im kinderspital zürich abgeklärt
und dann hat man schon mal luft und dank
[Musik]
sie bewirkt einen kurzschluss im gehirn
und ist eine der häufigsten
neurologischen erkrankungen
epilepsie bei einem gesunden menschen
ist das zusammenspiel von milliarden von
nervenzellen in unserem gehirn genau
aufeinander abgestimmt
beim epileptischen anfall ist dieses
gleichgewicht kurzzeitig gestört
viele nervenzellen entladen sich
plötzlich gleichzeitig diese entladungen
reizen einzelne gehirn gebiete oder das
ganze gehirn epilepsie kann genetisch
bedingt sein
als folge von stoffwechselerkrankungen
oder bei veränderungen der hirnstruktur
entstehen etwa bei tumoren infektionen
blutgerinnseln oder als folge eines
unfalls bei mehr als der hälfte der
fälle lässt sich die ursachen aber nicht
genau erklären
in der schweiz sind etwa 80.000 menschen
betroffen
sie hat er den titel die heilige
krankheit das ergriffen werden
und wenn ich so die patienten anschaue
was das im leben macht ist eigentlich
das schwierigste dieses unvorhersehbare
oder dieser kontrollverlust man kann
nicht bestimmen wann es kommt
und was bedeutet es für den einzelnen
für sein leben für seine
lebensgestaltung wenn dann immer wieder
vielleicht ein unterbruch oder dieser
autonomie verlust kommt sich natürlich
alles viel komplizierter natürlich hat
man diese sache das darf stimme machen
zum beispiel spiele velofahrerin
übergangen und natürlich selber hat man
immer angst dass ich vom ersten moment
gedauert angst
[Musik]
und zwei drittel der an epilepsie
erkrankten menschen können mit
medikamenten erfolgreich behandelt
werden oft gestaltet sich die suche nach
einem wirksamen medikament jedoch als
schwierig teils endet die suche
erfolglos
[Musik]
boß ein stück sie sind noch nehmen wurde
auch die wesens verträgt das fröhlich
nicolas sondern zum teil einfach traurig
im zimmer kock hat ich und einfach
lächerlich luft gelagert hat so
verstrich scheint sich das an wenn ich
ein erfolg und von meinen kollegen
nicolas anfälle können mit medikamenten
nicht verhindert werden
die appy klinik in zürich bietet nun
diesen schwierigen fällen hin für an dem
zuweisung brief stand so maximal zwölf
tage pro monat ohne anfall und er wurde
uns relativ früh also nach einem jahr
zugewiesen von den kollegen des
kinderspitals mit der frage kann man
nicola nicht durch eine operation helfen
der 10 jährige nicola bleibt während
einer woche in einem sogenannten
langzeit eg in der klinik dazu muss er
tag und nach dem bett bleiben während
seine hirnströme mit hilfe von
oberflächen elektroden aufgezeichnet
werden
da die epilepsie herde jedoch nicht
genau lokalisiert werden können schlagen
die ärzte der familie vor
mit hilfe eines operativen eingriffs
elektroden zu implantieren
die elektroden ermöglichen eine genaue
lokalisierung des anfalls ursprungs so
dass die epilepsie herde anschließend
chirurgisch entfernt werden könnten
[Musik]
ich bin nicht sicher ob ich das erklärt
wurden ist diese operation wird ablaufe
und was da alles gemacht wird dass ich
für ist schrecklich sie wählen also
taucht in eine ganz andere welt event
ihren operationen elektrode implantieren
dank man im ersten moment also da ist
man noch er tot
das kann egal und der mal trugen auch
nicht mir das überhaupt nicht vorstellen
dass du mich und mir hand wirklich
gefunden das mich nicht entscheiden es
gesund sind also am hirn operiere zwar
mit dem risiko dass dies könnte der frau
und am schluss werde mir tut dass es
noch schlimmer ist dass ich für die es
nicht kommen
oft sind es ja die eltern die für ihr
kind entscheiden müssen
und das geht ja oft erst wenn wenn die
eltern ganz sicher sind dass der nutzen
deutlich höher ist als als jetzt das
risiko einer operation
ich denke da muss man so lange
miteinander sprechen und begleiten bis
bis man zu der überzeugung kommt also
die betroffenen dass es jetzt die
richtige entscheidung
[Musik]
gemeinsam entscheidet sich die familie
also gegen eine operation eine völlig
andere entscheidung aber trifft nicola
ganz alleine
phoenix begeistert sie vor dem und
möchte in folge dass ich das besser
machen
die mechanik folge maschine auf große
städte und epilepsie nav was passiert
ist maschine kann ist für mich der folge
dass gott mir
du darfst es mir neuer dasselbe auch
gelernt hat hat er zurück ist muss ich
mich informieren
nicolas vater trifft abklärungen ob sein
sohn nicht doch seinen traumberuf
ausüben könnte sofort für und flamme
gefunden
geht nicht gibt's nicht bei zielpunkt
vor der bewerbung nikolassee vergisst
will sich eine von einer weniger schüler
wurden nach ruhig und hat sein
ich riet trotz epilepsie polymechaniker
nehme und der entscheid den stadtmeister
das habe ich gespürt hat er seine funde
notlage sei trotzdem handicap und für
mich ist sie das mir ihm da eine
schnupperlehre damit
es ist schön die oberflächen geht
und jetzt kann mit den tasten dann genug
und als programm laufen
das kann hier sind
ob ich mir
[Musik]
dann kühlt auf haltestelle gelebte
geworden oder
das fand im ganzen körper dose das muss
einen privaten der sozis davon für mich
eigentlich dass man in der mit über 100
bis zum new york times als komisches
gefühl dass ich unbeschreiblich ist man
spielt aber bis vor völlig verstand los
dass es gibt für mich kam viktor peters
dann gesehen nicht nur 16 nachlädt und
epic und soll es nämlich schon da war
aber bald demnach vorrangig in ok wenn
es nur ein spaß wie vor nach trost
nämlich gar nicht mehr wahr
es könne nicht sein dass das buch stellt
im schlaf und traum
so erhaltet normaler wie ist stage
minute bis zu einer minute gegen
manchmal später langsam zu mir dann ist
alles kräftig wo man fünfter bin extrem
irrt und habe mir mit treten und das
rund 1 langsam als nikolai 16 jahre alt
ist treten seine anfälle zunehmend
heftiger auf der hut
szenekenner nicht
auch für die schulen riefen heil 17 am
bahnhof lang auf und konnte im letzten
moment ein aufkommendes gleis kate bin
[Musik]
nicht ganz so groß aber im kolleg hat
mich vom preisniveau für lupe und die
zahl stetig steigende gefahr wenn ich an
durch 67 hat öfters stürzten sich
gegenüber vornehmen und öfters
verletzten aus ich habe mich sehr
gefreut wie der anruf kam und die
familie gesagt hat wir wollen
weitermachen jetzt können wir uns darauf
einlassen
wir überlegen dass er operiert werden
kann jetzt immer dafür also oft ist es
dann das sind dann immer viele worte
sondern man kennt sich ja auch gut
oder sie rufen an und sagen wir machen
weiter und dann dann weiß man was das
heißt auch nicola war dann viel aktiver
und hat auch seinen eltern mut gemacht
und gesagt ich habe da keine angst vor
und er hat auch da seinen eltern gezeigt
hier ich mache die entscheidung mit euch
zusammen also ihr seid nicht mehr die
einzigen die das entscheiden müssen
eigentlich hat man sich freut dann auf
das notebook ist ganz komisch aber ich
so dass sie vor der erlösung für euch im
sommer 2016 wird nicola von spezialisten
die chirurgischen klinik des
universitätsspitals zürich operiert
zwei angriffe werden durchgeführt bei
denen zuerst der anfangs ursprung
lokalisiert und anschließend das
epileptologie ne gewebe entfernt wird
nicolas chance auf anfalls freiheit
liegt bei etwa 70 prozent
[Musik]
er war knapp vier monate komplett
anfallsfrei dann kamen erste vor gefühle
oder die aura kam zurück und neun monate
nach der operation kam dann der erste
unfall wieder mit bewusstseinsstörungen
[Musik]
die phase wurden daraufhin wieder zurück
einfach nur der horror sie also die
erste zwei tag
januar in zehn von ihnen oder schwarze
und die kann man einfach mit dem
österreich hat mir eine quest beendet
das nun wieder einen zusammenbruch
dass interna der starken depressionen
hat
1 woche überhaupt keine lust mehr auf
nicht klappen
und natürlich vom 7 aber wieso macht man
das überhaupt und was bringt es
überhaupt am dritten tag ist wie
grabhorn tischen hat mit disco schweizer
seite immer wieder okay ich bin da und
ich bin bereit zum kampf auf
[Musik]
die unvorhersehbarkeit und der
kontrollverlust durch die anfällig
machen nicola schwer zu schaffen
das leben der ganzen familie wird auf
eine harte probe gestellt als nicole in
nikolas leben tritt wird der wunsch nach
einem selbstbestimmten autonom leben für
den 19-jährigen immer wichtiger
in ihm reifte entschluss dass er sich
erneut operieren lassen will
an der epi klinik wird in der folge
abgeklärt ob eine erneute operation
überhaupt möglich ist
ein funktionelles mm soll zeigen welche
hirnregionen bei einem weiteren
operativen eingriff allenfalls schaden
nehmen könnte bei nicola müssen wir
genau schauen dass wir nicht zu nahe an
die hirnregion kommen mit der wir wort
vom lesen können also wir können ja
manchmal ein ganzes wort wenn man nur
die kontur sieht wie zb auto dann das
prägnanteste und das ohne dann wissen
wir dass kann nur auto sein
diese hirnregion die ganz nah an der
region wo wir schon operiert haben und
da wollen wir relativ sicher sein dass
wir ihn sagen können wie nah wir an
diese region dran kommen wenn wir
operieren oder wie nah der anfangs
ursprung an dieser region dran ist und
deshalb müssen eben noch verschiedene
abklärungen passieren
die zweite operation wohl jetzt nach und
nach frankreich wo sie einst seine
verbunden mit rotkraut und hoffnung und
an zu sagen vielen dank für eure zeit
dass wir jetzt das weitere zu gehen in
der branche russischen abklärung bei
nicola fleck hat besprechen können die
involvierten ärzte tragen in einer
fallkonferenz alle auswertungen
zusammenlegen chancen und risiken
gegeneinander ab und fallen dann ihre
entscheidung war werden wir uns doch den
vorschlag einigen sollten das trotzdem
erst mal auch mit dem dauerregen
diskutieren wie die des berufs bewegung
[Musik]
ich persönlich 50 im moment weniger
gedanken wie es nachher wie sie was ein
teil des schlachthofs zerbrechliche
kraft ist ihr gefühl operation ohne die
kopfstimme und ist auch honecker und
zurückgewiesen
[Musik]
der moment ist gekommen heute erfährt
nicola von seiner ärztin judith kröll ob
eine erneute operation möglich ist bei
allen wichtigen gesprächen wird nicola
nebst seiner mutter auch von seinem
vater begleitet dieser zieht es jedoch
vor nicht vor die kamera zu treten
nach der eher gesagt wir müssen zwei
punkte noch während des 1
was sagt der chirurg und das andere war
wir möchten noch genauer hinschauen wie
nah das operationsgebiet an der
hirnregion ist die das lesen von wort
form verantwortlich ist und jetzt ist
einfach das dilemma dass diese
funktionelle untersuchungen gezeigt hat
dass diese hirnregionen ganz nah an dem
redaktions rand sind und der schlimmste
fall für dich wäre
du wirst durch die operation nicht
anfallsfrei und das lesen wenn für dich
noch mühsamer und noch schwieriger
also das heißt dann kannst du deine
ausbildung nicht mehr fertig machen
deshalb fanden alle experten die
zusammen waren nicht der richtige
zeitpunkt hier weiterzumachen weil du
musst verstehen können was bedeutet dass
wenn ich jetzt wort form nicht mehr gut
lesen kann wenn das passiert versucht
deine ausbildung das ist jetzt noch ein
jahr weiterzumachen versucht die
ausbildung abzuschließen die zeit die
brauchst du jetzt und und die brauchen
wir eine und wir setzen uns dann auch
wieder zusammen würden wir zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt nicht
einlass zu machen über uns jemand nicht
dass das das geht nicht du möchtest
die app anfälle loswerden das verstehen
da war nichts und lasse für jubel
dagegen bis minister ja aber weißt du
wenn du jetzt keine ausbildung hat das
wichtigste gesundheit und land ausbilden
ja aber dafür für ein selbstständiges
leben das heißt dass man auch jetzt bei
uns in der jetzigen situation ein
[Applaus]
wir möchten alle wir möchten alle nicht
dass das das nun schaden davonträgt den
gehen wir nicht mehr reparieren kann nun
aber besonders schlechter qualität und
versuchen noch einfach mal zu überlegen
was das heißt wenn eben nicht der
erwünschte erfolg eintritt und als zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt die risiken schwerer
wiegen als die nutzen
ich weiß was du 17
wenn das jetzt wirklich gibt die zeit
[Musik]
sie gibt uns auch die zeit
und lieben
[Musik]
für die nikoläuse welt nahmen zum
zweiten mal im jahr ist erstmal der fall
ricco sind ist es ganz schlimm
und jetzt zum zweiten mal vom hofe dem
wohnungs von nicola nachzugeben jetzt
egal was passiert welches defizit kommt
hauptsache er operiert mit dem können
wir nicht nachgeben
er kann diese konsequenz nicht
voraussehen vor allen dingen diese
doppelte negative konsequenz ich bekomme
ein neues defizit und ich behalte die
anfänge weil das das ist ja auch
realistisch weil der sohn hoher
leidensdruck ist fällt ihm das jetzt
schwer da die waage zu halten und
deshalb könnte man gar nicht zustimmen
sondern dass das darf man nur wenn auch
der patient die konsequenzen versteht
und um vorab mit voraus denken kann
[Musik]
hier zieht sieht nachricht dass es nicht
geht ist schwierig aber jeden tag wird
die einfachen eröffnet sich trotz
niedriger ist mit er ist nicht nur im
zimmer songs darunter sogar mal mit uns
nicht über rang und der radioshow für
das ist schon mal sehr gut
ich wünsche mir einfach dass wir auf
kurs
wichtig ist für ihn
der beliebsten sauber hat sich gar
nichts geändert
mit command und das akzeptiere ich muss
halt damit muss eine perspektive findet
bestaunen
also ich mache mir im moment
unterstützen oder wirtschaft der familie
[Musik]
es vergehen drei schwierige monate in
denen nicola heftige anfälle erleidet
innerhalb von zwei wochen bricht er sich
bei stürzen in der unterführung in den
wald zweimal den kiefer und verliert
insgesamt 18
der leidensdruck wird immer größer
nicola entscheidet sich an der ep klinik
psychiatrische hilfe in anspruch zu
nehmen
die handlichen er will einfach die
blockaden abgebaut und ich habe sie zum
wieder neu und dass er in angriff nehmen
das ist die vorletzte im wind nicola
drängt auf weitere untersuchungen
aufgrund der hohen verletzungsgefahr
durch stürze prüfen die ärzte erneut die
möglichkeit eines operativen eingriffs
das risiko einer leseschwäche als folge
der operation ist allerdings hoch
[Musik]
die behandelnde ärztin erklärt nicola
dass die operation nur dann durchführbar
ist wenn die anfälle von einer eindeutig
lokalisiert barren stelle kennen wie
zwei jahre zuvor planen die ärzte zuerst
tiefen elektroden zu implantieren welche
nicolas hirnströme während der anfälle
detailliert aufzeichnen sollen am
universitätsspital zürich erklärt
chirurg niklaus kreienbühl der nicola
bereits 2016 operiert hat den eingriff
in allen details berichtet dass die
genauso gut gott wie sony oder das ziel
die 1
am frühen morgen des 6 august 2008 10
werden am universitätsspital zürich die
tiefen elektroden implantiert
[Musik]
elektroden implantiert bekommen damit
wir einen ge ge aus dem irren ableiten
können dazu haben wir geplant
verschiedene elektroden im gewebe zu
implantieren
das ist ja nicht so fürchterlich einfach
denn es gibt jede menge blutgefäße im
gehirn und die man ganz gern herum
fahren möchte und darum
das habe ich hier wege gesucht 7 mm
genau einhalten müssen und dann diese
elektroden sicher platzieren zu können
und 29
das schöne ist die elektroden sind
stumpf und wenn in der tiefe ein
blutgefäß auf dem weg liegen würde
dann wird das durch gefäß in der regel
zur seite gehen und es passiert gar
nichts
problem machen und blutgefäße auch der
helle oberfläche die sind nämlich an der
hirnhaut fest wenn ich dort einem
bohrloch mache das mache ich ja im
prinzip alles blind
dann muss ich mich darauf verlassen
können dass darunter kein blutgefäß ist
das nicht ausweichen kann
jetzt zur kontrolle die postoperative
computertomografie mit den elektroden
hier und was wir sehen ist dass wir hier
im vorderen depot campus auf der linken
seite sehr schön 23 kontakte drin haben
ich hätte keine tiefen elektrode sehr
schön eine ganz ohne rundum zufrieden
[Musik]
am tag nach der operation erholt sich
nicola vielen strapazen des eingriffs
zurück an der ep klinik schöpft der neue
kraft das mikro hoffen konnte erklärt
dass wir operieren
dass das jetzt alles gut funktioniert
damit der monitoring da und das
funktioniert dann bin ich glücklich
jetzt sollte man sie das servicemobil
anschluss eigentlich kooperieren mit
erfolg denn ist
bevor nicolas anfälle aufgezeichnet
werden können wissen die implantierten
elektroden nach einem genauen schema mit
dem computersystem verbunden werden
zusätzlich werden oberflächen elektroden
angebracht
[Musik]
der staub gemacht haben ich mich so sehr
getroffen gestützt und das darf jetzt
nicht machen will sollte nach ganzen wm
erfolg ist es dann halt wieder ein stück
zu einer normalen leben will
zuversichtlich aber realistisch
pl
[Musik]
wir sind hier mit tensid monitoring
überwachen die patienten 24 stunden am
tag
jetzt haben wir den nicola gerade da mit
implantierten elektroden wir schauen
jetzt nach den veränderungen im eeg und
warten auf wir haben einmal das eeg das
laufende meistens in das oberflächen
elektroden war nikola ist jetzt sehr
spezielle fall dass wir implantierte
elektroden haben und zusätzlich läuft
noch tage und nachts ein video mit
optimal ist ein chrome ich habe das ist
so es vergehen vier endlose tage ohne
anfälle
erst nachdem die medikamentendosis stark
reduziert wird folgen die ersehnten
anfälle
man sieht sobald er nicole ein anfall
hat am eg am besten dann hat es
pathologische veränderungen bzw 1 ablauf
merken sie sich sobald der nicole ein
anfall hat gehen wir sofort rein machen
dann spezielle testungen befragen ihn
testen ihn was er kann was geht sprache
motorik gedächtnis
nach sechs tagen im intensiv monitoring
informiert die ärztin nicola ob die
ersehnte operationen durchgeführt werden
kann
genau wir sind fündig geworden
wir haben jetzt nach große runde noch
mal zusammengesessen und wirklich alles
angeschaut und uns genau gedanken
gemacht und was man als allererstes
sagen kann ich habe genug anfälle
die vier großen anfälle sie zeigen uns
zumindest dass sie auf der linken seite
sind und nicht auf der rechten seite
zeigen uns aber nicht unmittelbar den
anfangs ursprung aber alles zusammen
spricht nicht gegen eine operation
aber weil es halt nicht so schön eng
begrenztes wie man sich das gerne
gewünscht hätte
mit einer schlechteren chance auf
allenfalls freiheit sagen wir
unterdurchschnittlich
aber wir glauben schon dass sie mit der
op tatsächlich eine chance haben dass
die anfälle aufführen können oder aber
zumindestens deutlich weniger werken
risiko für sie die tus lag sie das heißt
die lesefähigkeit wird wahrscheinlich
tatsächlich schlechter werden damit
müssen sie rechnen frühestens zum mord
das ist eine entscheidung die kino sie
treffen und das ist wirklich eine
schwere das ist ein reines audio sei
aber das sind top milch und mindert
wünsche schaut einfach das wohl noch
niedrig und dinge dass chance auf eine
voll gestochen immer so groß wenn man
sicher keine wünsche oder schaut bewusst
könnte ich jetzt da doch ich wie größte
möglichkeit
schlussendlich aber man dann definitiv
alles probiert
morgen ist weiblich die liegt die
definitiven operation kommt aber der
geschichte wenn man das alles macht ist
ja was von wichtigsten branchen und
druckte ein bild über das mega
sympathische möglichst gleich mitliefern
ja auch in die ferien kreuzte 78 durch
die minister klug
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ja
hilft guardiola ich weiß mit humor
schafft ja
[Musik]
geschlafen
dies berge
[Musik]
vorsprung sie betragen
anatomie der partie
schweizweit werden in unterschiedlichen
spielte elan jährlich rund 80 epilepsie
chirurgischer eingriffe durchgeführt
am unispital zürich schon seit über 80
jahren
aufgrund der fortschritte in der
neurochirurgie sind sie sehr sicher
geworden und dennoch jeder eingriff am
herum stellt ein risiko dar
der erfahrene chirurg niklaus kreienbühl
muss stets abwägen wie viel gewebe
entfernt ein millimeter zu viel und der
patient könnte eine wichtige funktion
verlieren außerdem ration haben sie sich
schon sehr riskant dafür mit
sprachfunktion also nicht einfach reden
aber das sprachverständnis drucker der
redefluss der karneval pro berger stand
und das risiko ist tot operationsrisiko
kein land
august einladen
als unsere funktionen von der ipi klinik
ist dass wir jetzt hier den operateur
unterstützen indem wir während der
operation
das eeg ableiten und hinsichtlich der
operation grenzen sagen können wo genau
elektrischen potenziale auftreten in
welchem ausmaß sie auftreten und so den
operateuren anhalt geben können wo der
schwerpunkt der obmann hat sondern auch
stattfinden soll und wie ausgedehnt
gegebenenfalls die operation werden wird
jetzt bin ich sehr froh mit anderen blut
schweiß und tränen aber die ist ganz
groß was dort vom linken live verlauten
das verletzt ist ein anspruchsvoller
ja er mixa auch mehr jungs eines
funktion sich egal ob alaba sich einfach
schwierig für der patient abtreten
das heißt betreten also das ist es diese
händigkeit oder mit einer zeit mit
zum vergleich
[Musik]
die operation ist geplant so in etwa
vier stunden gange und wir haben jetzt
noch mal in der zweite versuch einmal
versuchen stellte dempsey herz entfernen
da ist man vorantreibt
teilweise ist es sehr schwierig sie die
standsicherheit erstellen
das risiko wurde sprach sinne zahlen wir
aber dass auch mit hoffen lassen
[Musik]
und die kooperation ist fertig
also insbesondere warum aber in wechselt
also bei eingestiegen wo sollen wir sich
vorstellt dass da einfach im schnitt
drin ist und da immer besorgen oder
gemacht wollte nicht also dann bieten
sich als neues labor ist neues kapitel
auf 1 aber setzt ein volk dieser ruf als
freiheit da ist also der familie hat
einfach darauf dass nach ursachen aber
noch ein wunder bis jetzt nicht
unbedingt hätte können also wie zum
beispiel dass er jetzt auch mit mehreren
ist wasser schwimmen und welcher form
wiederfinden einmal auf den zahn fühlen
sich allerdings stoßen
einfach so dass der ausbau möglich
standen pizza tonno
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das sind das vier meter die sind die
operation klopfen ist und und tod des
vaters
um lhasa ist allgemein nun unnötig
verloren
eben noch gut lassen wie vorher in japan
bin immer lustig sein beruf serbien
[Musik]
höchst
die nachkontrollen an der gp klinik und
am universitätsspital zürich zeigen ein
erfreuliches ergebnis
jetzt im moment ist es einfacher willen
ja es ist ein langer weg sie sich
einfach sehr wichtig dass die
kooperation kein fan und wieder mal ein
politisches gefühl im kopf und die augen
sich alles weg ja die eine stimme gehört
das ist auch wenn die risiken auftreten
auch notrationen
die analyse hat er alles nötige defizit
das sieht man natürlich sehr dankbar
[Musik]
letzte mal einen koffer packt für ein
spital offenthal täter untersuchen der
und
operationen und jetzt die zukunft wie
die credit suisse flug und auf dass das
so bliebe wird
[Musik]
was ich sehe ich gezielt hat dieser
regelmäßigen einfach auf team und müssen
funktionieren und jetzt wofür man
natürlich dass man den könnt
wirkliche selbständigkeit logo und das
rücklicht und vienenburg machen
mit den folgenden sieben monaten kann
sich nicola voll und ganz seiner
ausbildung widmen
befreit von der angst vor unfällen mit
einem festen ziel vor augen
im sommer schließt nicola seine
ausbildung zum polymechaniker
erfolgreich ab
auch über ein jahr nach der operation
ist der anfallsfrei
[Musik]